hi welcome to science hangout from
science mission
I'm Sadashiva five from science mission
today we have dr. Suzanne l'épée
associate professor of radiology and
chemistry and Cyclone facility director
at the University of Alabama at
Birmingham Birmingham with us in
addition to publishing several articles
on peer-reviewed journals and membership
in several societies dr. avi has won
several awards to our critic in 2014 she
has won Marie Curie lecture
International Conference on isotopes in
2010 she won Mario Nicolini prize from
Italy in 2010 she won Harry Harry grey
Family Fund our metals in medicine in
New Hampshire in 2007 she won
president's research stipend Simon
Fraser University in 2006 he won several
hours one of them being student travel
bursary to expose iam chemistry poster
competition student travel again
bursaries from midwinter for attending
Midwinter Meeting in Arizona in 20 2005
she won student again award to attend
Pacific Rim chemistry symposium and
chemistry oral competition she won
second place in SF you welcome dr. Lappe
oh nice to be here thanks for joining
science hangout thanks for inviting me
so good good good good to have you here
with us and Kenny can you tell us about
yourself your background your education
etc sure so I started off a man in
chemistry and then became more
interested in chemistry with radioactive
isotopes I did a master's degree looking
at
reactions that happen in SARS so I was
really interested in nuclear reactions
that happened in supernovae and then I
started to transition more to the
medical field so I became interested in
how we can use Radio isotopes as tools
in medicine and particularly in medical
imaging so I did my PhD at Simon Fraser
University looking at isotopes for
medicine and then I could have postdoc
at the University of California in San
Francisco where I continued to look at
imaging agents mostly for cancer and
then I was at Washington University in
st. Louis as a assistant professor and
then a tenured professor and then in
2015 I moved to the University of
Alabama at Birmingham as a tenured
associate professor where I run the
cyclotron facility and develop new
molecular imaging agents ok so can you
talk to us about your mentors role
models you have come across in your
research career sure I've had I've been
very lucky have had wonderful mentors so
starting with my PhD supervisors dr. Tom
Ruth and dr. John Dorian really gave me
that love for the field of radio
chemistry and how we can use radioactive
materials for a whole host of things
including medical imaging then my
postdoctoral advisor Henry Van Brocklin
again a lot of enthusiasm and really
started to learn more about how can we
develop radioactive tracers and then
translate them into people and how can
we get them more translational bit and
more into clinical trials and that sort
of thing then when I moved to the
Washington University and st. Louis I
was fortunate enough to work with dr.
Mike Welch who again convinced me that
you really could have a program where
you go all the way from particle
accelerators making radioactive isotopes
to doing the chemistry to putting all
these things together you know small
animal trials and then human imaging as
well so really gave me the you know the
love for the breadth of the field and
I'm also training and mentoring and
having all the students along the way so
I learned a lot from my mentor
okay and I know you are busy with doing
all the research as well as maintaining
the facility so what are you building
you're like what are your hobbies other
than the research so I'm a chemist and
actually like most chemists we like to
cook because it's really just different
applied chemistry so I cook a lot home I
do a lot of experimenting I guess my
husband and I like to travel so travel
and see new things and new different
areas of the world so I think those are
my two main hobbies okay and let's talk
about your lab people so can you please
talk about them like how many grad
student pushed out so like what do they
do and off so right now I have four
graduate students so three of them are
in chemistry and one is in biochemistry
I have two undergraduates and they're
both biomedical engineering I have I
guess three postdoctoral fellows and
they're all radio chemists as well so
they're working on new molecular imaging
agents and then I have three PhD level
staff scientists that are really sort of
the core of my team and really help me
run my program I also have we have an
excellent pharmacist that works for us
and helps us transition some of these
compounds into clinical trials and then
we have a number of engineers that help
with the cyclotron operations okay
and how do you like that looks like
there is a bunch of people in your
organization so how do you manage like
the time with them advising them and all
those things I meet with everybody once
a week so everybody gets a one-on-one
meeting and then we have a group meeting
where we all get together and we make
sure everybody knows what's going on so
is the schedule and then a lot of
informal meetings you know a lot of
really good ideas come out of these
hallway conversations we're just having
lunch with somebody and so I I try to
interact with everybody as much as
possible okay and I have seen some of
your recent work which is pretty
interesting and can you please tell us
more about it and
start video presentation if you don't
mind sure so I'll just jump right in
then and I'll go ahead so I should just
share my screen now yeah Sheila okay
great
so I'm very happy to be here and I'll
talk a little bit about our work I've
titled are my presentation from isotope
to images and we're going to talk about
radioactive materials as tools both in
medicine but also some recent work we've
done in basic science so we use isotopes
for something called the tracer
principle and so in nuclear medicine in
many areas of basic science we can use
these radioactive atoms as tracers so
the idea is is that the tracer behaves
in a similar way to the components of
the system that you're investigating but
you're not altering the system in any
fashion so we're using these tracers to
sort of look inside the system see
what's going on but we're not trying to
change it so it's really diagnostic
procedures and of course the ultimate
concept is that the tracer concentration
can be measured so as an example of this
we look at george de hevesy so he was a
pioneer in radio chemistry a long time
ago he worked in Manchester in the early
1900's he worked for Rutherford Ernest
Rutherford that many people may have
heard of and he suspected that his
landlady serving in recycled food so he
takes the Sunday night roast and he
spikes the roast with radium the radium
is used as a tracer radium's and the
roast and lo and behold he finds the
radium and Wednesday's hash so he's
using this radium as a tracer to find
out where the roast goes and so building
on this we can kind of expand on this
idea and we can make radio
pharmaceuticals so the idea is this a
radio pharmaceutical is a drug that's
labeled with radioactive isotope to
image a biological process or to deliver
therapy to a specific disease site the
overall chemical structure desert
determines the biological properties of
the drug where the drug is going to go
how it's going to clear out of the body
what it targets and the radioisotope
with a radionuclide that you're attached
to your drug determines the imaging or
therapeutic properties so I what I'm
showing here
can you see my mouse it's okay yeah I
have our radioactive isotope and I've
got some kind of linker and then what I
call a Pharma Kapur this is the the drug
that we're talking about so as an
example of this I can take D glucose so
this is just glucose is a sugar molecule
and I can tag it with a radioactive
fluorine atom so that's this red
fluorine 18 here and I can essentially
make a radioactive sugar molecule that
we can call to fluoro to deoxy glucose
or FDG for short and I'll come back to
that in a minute so our group is really
interested in how do we make these
isotopes and how do we separate them so
that we can get them in a useful form
for chemistry we work on the radio
chemistry for new imaging agents so how
do we attach those Radio isotopes to the
molecular imaging agent the
characterization of new
radiopharmaceutical so do they bind to
the target that we design them to
Boddington translation into clinical
trials and then support we support
ongoing clinical trials in molecular
imaging as well so let's go back to the
radiopharmaceutical
so we've got this targeting compound
that's labeled with this radionuclide
for imaging and therapy the structure of
the compound determines the biological
properties the targeting the clearance
the different receptor interactions and
the radioactive label that we've
attached determines imaging or
therapeutic properties so we have our
targeting moiety we label it with our
radioactive atom then we have our
volunteer here and inject them with our
compound and it essentially lights up
like a beacon telling us where the drug
goes and we look at imaging with
something called positron emission
tomography and this is a very sensitive
tool so this is how we measure the
radioactivity that's in a person and it
can give us information about the
biological and physiological processes
in a non-invasive manner and that
really key so we're injecting
radioactive materials into people and
then we can image them without doing
surgery and without taking a biopsy
so how positron emission tomography
works we have this radioactive atom
that's here it admits what we call a
positron so that's this e+ here the
positron is the antimatter of an
electron so in the body when our
antimatter hits our matter or in our
electron they annihilate and when they
annihilate they give rise to these two
gamma rays and because of conservation
of momentum these two gamma rays are
emitted back to back so when this
happens in a person these gamma rays are
emitted back to back we can use our
detectives to see them and then we get
what's called a line of response if we
these two detectors fire at the same
time we know that event happened
somewhere along this line we collect
many many millions of these events and
then we can form a picture to determine
where the radioactivity was so let's go
back to glucose so we can use glucose to
look at to look at sugar metabolism so
we take our glucose we've replaced this
hydroxyl group here with this
radioactive fluorine atom this is a very
sensitive tool to look at patients that
have cancer cancer cells take up a lot
of sugar they're growing very fast we
call it their what we call
hypermetabolic and so we can essentially
get a map of metabolism in the human
body and so this is a woman that was
actually scanned at our institution she
has been diagnosed with t-cell lymphoma
and the dark spots are indicating high
uptake of let's see if this works
this is okay high uptake of our FDG and
so you can see normal uptake in the
brain you can see normal excretion
through the bladder and normal excretion
through the kidneys here and
unfortunately for this woman you can see
a number of uptake spots that are
indicative of different metastatic
tumors as the results of this woman's
lymphoma so we're using the ftg to help
diagnose this woman so she underwent
several rounds of
therapy and then came back for a
follow-up scan so this is showing the
follow-up scan still you see normal
uptake in the brain
normal excretion through the bladder and
normal excretion through the kidneys but
now you can see the pretty dramatic
difference between the metabolism before
the treatment and after the treatment so
we can use FDG to follow patients during
the course of treatment so ftg is great
and this is a wonderful way to look at
cancer metabolism but we're interested
in a lot more things than just
metabolism so we would like to look at
detection of cancer cells prediction of
treatment response receptor status
oxygenation micro environment and a
whole host of parameters that can help
us give information to the physician to
determine how best to treat the patient
so we really want to tailor treatment
that's specific to a patient's cancer
and so we can get different information
with different tracers and so this is
just a literature figure is shown here
so this is a man that has an F D G scan
so this is again showing sugar
metabolism and he's actually had a tumor
resected on his scalp so you can see
this little sort of blank spot here and
he's being scanned again to look for
residual tumor unfortunately you can see
a number of dark spots both in the spine
also still on the scalp this is just
normal liver and then bladder but if we
scan with another agent gallium 68 dota
talk we can see a number of other sites
lighting up really a lot of sites in the
spine and in the hips and gallium 68
donut ox specifically targets a receptor
on cancer cells called the somatostatin
receptor and this is really important
because there are certain therapies that
target the somatostatin receptor so with
this gentleman we're not only
determining where is cancer cells are
but the fact that those cancer cells
have somatostatin receptors and that
this man is probably going to be a very
good candidate for somatostatin targeted
radiotherapy so now we want to build all
of our compounds we need to think about
what kind of isotopes
are we going to attach to our molecules
and when we think about those isotopes
we think about the chemistry the
half-life the different decayed
properties the availability of those
isotopes and the purity and so some of
the more common pet isotopes I'm calling
standard pet isotopes are shown here and
so here you can show the nuclear
reaction that we use to make those
isotopes as well as the half-life the
half-life is the time it takes for half
of those isotopes to decay so we can
make carbon 11 by proton bombardment on
nitrogen 14 we call this a P alpha
reaction carbon 11 has a half-life of 20
minutes we can make fluorine 18 by a PN
reaction by a radiating oxygen 18
fluorine 18 is a half-life of two hours
similarly we can make nitrogen 13 and
oxygen 15 which is a half-life of 10
minutes in two minutes so carbon
fluorine nitrogen oxygen these are a
very nice tool box an excellent place to
get started and we can use our chemistry
to attach these radioactive isotopes to
numerous small molecules however the
drawback with some of these isotopes is
that they have very short half-lives so
we're losing half of our molecules in
the case of carbon 11 in 20 minutes or
half of our molecules in 2 hours and so
your chemistry has to be very fast and
this also limits the biological imaging
half-life or the biological imaging time
that you have let's say you want to
image some kind of process that happens
in a patient for several hours or
several days you're probably going to
need something different than these
isotopes so our group works a lot with
radio metals and often these radio
metals have longer half-lives so we can
use them to probe longer biological
processes we can use these to expand our
toolbox so we get a variety of
half-lives and different decay
characteristics that are available and
these can be used some of them can be
used for both imaging and targeted
therapy when we're thinking about metals
if you remember your chemistry a little
bit you need to work on the coordination
chemistry so what we want to make sure
is that we are basically developing
compounds
hold those metals in place so that the
metal stays with the targeting agent so
we really want to know where the
targeting agent goes and not just where
the free metal goes and so this we need
to really think about stable key lasers
so this is our tool box this is the
chart of the nuclides and you can think
of the toolbox or the try to the
nuclides as an expanded periodic table
so there's about 3,000 known isotopes
we've got protons going here on the y
axis and neutrons going here on the x
axis so every row is a different element
and every box is a different isotope and
what I'm just showing here is the color
coded Miss so that we can see the
different half-lives with relationship
to where they are on the chart of
nuclides the ones that we're interested
in that that decay by positron emission
are roughly found here there's several
hundred of them so this is where we go
looking for new isotopes to build our
radioactive tracers so if we're looking
at radio metals you can imagine the the
periodic table the first row radio
metals are found roughly here and if we
zoom in we can get a better look at what
metals are there so this shows nickel
copper zinc and gallium the black ones
are the stable isotopes and the colored
ones are the radioactive isotopes so we
can start to look for isotopes that
decay by positron emission and also have
reasonable half-lives so here we've got
copper 61 which is a half-life of three
hours copper 62 which is a half-life of
10 minutes which is a little short con
for 64 which is a half-life of 12 hours
gallium 66 which has a half-life of nine
hours and gallium 68 which has a
half-life of a little over an hour if we
go a little farther up the chart of the
nuclides we can look at second row
transition metals and again zooming in
we get strontium yttrium zirconium and
niobium and here we see it's room 86
that has a half-life of fourteen point
seven hours in zirconium 89 that has a
half-life of about three days and I'm
going to focus a lot on zirconium 89
moving forward because we've done a lot
of work on this isotope before so what
how does the psychotron facility work so
we enable a broad scope of research and
cutting-edge patient care and we we have
projects that range from isotope
reductions so how do we make these
isotopes to developing and supplying
these new molecular imaging agents for
both clinical trials and routine patient
care so again kind of a broad scope of
activities this is the layout of the
cyclotron facility so you see here this
big dark box that sort of in purple at
the bottom this is actually the
cyclotron vault so this is where the
particle accelerator is and I'll talk a
little bit more about that in a minute
adjacent to the vault we have this grey
area this is the equipment room so this
is where all the sort of auxilary
equipment to run the cyclotron is the
yellow area is the pre-clinical radio
chemistry lab so this is a non human use
area that we use for developmental
chemistry this is where a lot of our
students work along the the side here we
have our GMP facility so this is a clean
air you have to gown up to go in there
this is where we make all the human use
radio pharmaceuticals and you see these
boxes here these boxes are called hot
cells and they're essentially led
shielded areas that we can use to
prepare our radioactive materials in a
very safe manner next to the GMP
facility we have this green area which
is the quality control area so here we
make sure that the radio pharmaceuticals
are pure we make sure that they're the
right compound we make sure that they're
sterile we've set it ready and safe for
human use injection so this is the
quality control area and then in sort of
pink here we have our radio pharmacy so
this is where we actually draw the final
dose and we prepare the syringe where
we'll get injected into the patient this
is the sort of close-up of the vault
here so this is actual cyclotron here so
the cyclotron I'll talk a little bit
more about that in a minute has been--
lines on both sides so we use the
cyclotron to accelerate protons
to actually induce nuclear reactions to
make these radioactive isotopes so this
is the cyclotron here it was made by a
company called advanced cyclotron
systems are located in Vancouver it
accelerates protons to 15 to 24 mega
electron volts so millions of electron
volt protons it has to extraction ports
on either side and these four beam lines
so we can use the cyclotron to radiate
either solid liquid or gas targets so we
pick different target materials
depending on the radioactive isotopes
that we want to make this is just
showing the psychotron when it's open
and this is a cyclotron when it's closed
so you can see here's one of the
beamline
on the far side there and the cyclotron
is in the heavily shielded vault for a
radiation safety okay so how does a
cyclotron work so the general principle
is that you have an alternating voltage
with a frequency equal to the orbital
frequency of the particles that's
applied between the DS and this helps to
accelerate either positive or negative
particles so what does that mean
essentially the cyclotron is housed in a
big magnet so here I was just shown orth
and South here and then there's these
two electrodes inside the cyclotron and
because of these electrode shape they're
called DS so our cyclotron actually
accelerates at h- so this is a proton
with two electrons attached to it you
inject these into the center of the
cyclotron and because this is a charged
particle its contained in the magnetic
field it starts to move in a circle so
when our h- gets to what we call this
gap in between the two DS we make this
deep pause or negatively charged and
this D positively charged and our h-
gets accelerated across the gap it
starts to move in a larger circle and
then it gets to the next gap then when
it gets to the next gap we make this D
negative and this D positive and it gets
accelerated again now it's moving in a
larger circle gets to the next gap then
we make this D negative 50 positive it
gets a little kick again and it goes in
a bigger and bigger circle so in
this fashion we can use a small machine
to accelerate protons to very high
energies so this is our machine so you
can see here this is the magnet and I
apologize the pictures a little on an
angle because I would sort of crunched
under the machine trying to get a
photograph of it so this is the machine
when it's open this is the top plate and
this is the bottom plate and so while
our DS are a little bit funny shape
they're not exactly G shape they're
these sort of pie wedges they serve the
same function so these electrodes are
switching polarity in order to get our
protons or h- to accelerate in a circle
to faster and faster energies so once we
get our protons accelerated we need to
actually radiate targets to induce the
nuclear reaction so as I mentioned
before our targets can be gases liquids
or solids and so we can irradiated
nitrogen-14
gas target this is the P alpha reaction
to make carbonyl limit so we contain
nitrogen-14 gas and essentially a
cylindrical tube and irradiated with our
protons we can irradiated liquid targets
so this is a P alpha reaction on
oxygen-16
that's just as water to make nitrogen
13:00 we can have a PN reaction on
oxygen 18 to make fluorine 18 and this
is an enriched oxygen target we can also
radiate solid targets so this is a PN
reaction to make copper 64 and then a PN
reaction this is actually it should be
making zirconium 89 on metallic it's
remedy 9 so this just shows some of our
target stations so this is actually
what's at the end of those beam lines we
have a gas target here so this is that
long cylinder that's probably say 10 or
15 inches long that contains our
high-pressure gas to make our carbon 11
these are our two water targets they
both contain about a milliliter of water
that we array D 8 to make the isotopes
and this is one of our high current
solid target stations for radiating
solid targets this is one of our smaller
targets that we call the coin target
so these coins as you can see here
they're about the size of a quarter so
we can electroplate or basically deposit
different materials on these coins in
order to radiate them to make our
different isotopes and so here I'm just
showing this is it reom that's sputtered
on top of niobium we can put them in
this little coin target so this is the
coin slot here the proton beam comes
from this side and then this sits at the
end of one of those beam lines and this
just shows the actual physical target so
again the proton beam comes from this
side and this is that coin slot that I
pointed out before this is our
high-power target station so this is
actually a larger target so this is
about the size you think about the size
of a cell phone you can electroplate
different materials on here on this
little copper wedge this plunger here
pushes this up into the holder and then
the beam comes in from this side here in
order to irradiated argot and again this
just shows the actual target station so
this is what you see if you go into our
vault I showed the GMP space on the map
a little bit before I just wanted to
show what that sort of hallway of hot
cells looks like so you can see here
these are the manipulator arms that we
use to manipulate things inside the hot
cells so that we don't we not exposed to
radiation we have different sized hot
cells that we also have an area that we
can draw doses for human use the
clinical quality control area has
different things to ensure that the
radio pharmaceuticals are high quality
so we have HPLC GC t LC so a lot of
analytical equipment in order to
identify our proper radio
pharmaceuticals this just shows a list
of the different radio pharmaceuticals
that we currently have in use I'm not
going to go over them all but I just
wanted to show that these radio
pharmaceuticals can be used for a wide
variety of things so this n blue R 5
compound is actually looking at a
receptor that's very important in
addiction so we're doing some neurology
studies this FLT looks at proliferation
so how fast cells are growing
we're looking at cardiac blood flow so
we're doing some heart studies here with
this n13 compound I mentioned dota Tate
where we're looking at somatostatin
receptor status and a number of other
tracers again a toolbox of tracers to
look at different parameters to help
physicians decide how to treat patients
we also look at a number of different
isotopes so looking at the toolbox of
isotopes in order to make these
different compounds so we routinely
produce for an 18 carbon 11 nitrogen 13
but we also have many research projects
looking at development of new isotopes
and in fact this is what most of my PhD
students work on so looking at let's say
scandium 44 that has a four hour
half-life looking at how do you make
targets how do you radiate them how do
you separate it out and actually get it
attached to interesting molecules and
again I'll focus a little bit on
zirconium 89 and some of our examples so
so Konya 89 is a very interesting
isotope and it has a half-life of three
days and it's really well matched if we
want to look at the pharmacokinetics of
antibodies antibodies are larvae large
proteins they circulate in the blood for
a long period of time and so we can
actually image the distribution of those
and see how well they're targeting the
tumor how long they take to clear from
the body and also estimating estimating
dosimetry from a chemistry Stanford so
according in 89 is also very interesting
as it's quite inert to biological
systems we have previously done a lot of
work with copper 64 this is very
difficult to work with because you have
a lot of enzymes and proteins in your
body that use copper and so you have to
really work to sequester it from these
biological processes zirconium 89 is
quite inert to biological systems and so
we can make very stable complexes we're
interested in the positron decay so
that's this beta plus here so it decays
by positron decay 22% of the time and we
so we can use this isotope for PET
imaging here I'm just showing the decay
scheme so Zaccone
nine decays to its room so when we think
about producing zirconium 89 we need to
think about the probability that these
nuclear reactions are going to happen if
we radiate atrium target with a proton
beam how many zirconium 89 atoms are we
going to make and so what I'm showing
here is this cross section so the cross
section is essentially the probability
that a nuclear reaction is going to
happen and here is the incident energy
of the proton beam so in blue here you
see the atrium 89 P n reaction to make
zirconium 89 so this is their nuclear
reaction that we actually want to happen
and you can see a peak somewhere around
15 MeV if we go higher than that you
start to see it remain a 9p to n
reaction giving user Honi maybe eight
zirconium 88 is very long-lived
contaminant we don't want it in our 8
remaining 9 production so what we have
to do is basically moderate the proton
beam so that we get the interim 89 PN to
make the zirconium 89 but we don't get
the P to win to make Sur Coney mediate
so it's very you have to be very careful
about the incident energy and the
nuclear reactions that are taking place
while you're radiating that so I'm just
zooming in here again on the chart of
the nuclides so we're starting with it's
room 89 this is a PN reaction to give
you the coning 89 and we want to avoid
that P to end reaction to give you
zirconium 88 which has a half-life of 80
days so what we do is we take our proton
beam that starts around 16 MeV
we run it through what we call a de
greater this degrades the energy of the
proton beam so that we have a 12.5 MeV
proton beam that's a radiating the
yttrium target we purify our zirconium
89 by ion exchange chromatography so
when we're done with the irradiation we
have our zirconia meeting on it's in
this matrix of it remain a nine and we
dissolve the term 89 a hydrochloric acid
and then we put it through a resin by
changing what we're putting
that resin we can differentially elude
off the yttrium 89 and the zirconium 89
so this is just showing the
functionality of the resin if we we load
on the dissolve target then we wash the
target in hydrochloric acid then we wash
the column again in water and this is
all to make sure that we get out all
that it's reom target material then we
can elude our radioactivity in one molar
oxalic acid and here you can see the
profile of the radioactivity Ellucian so
the zirconium 89 stains bound to the
column until we elude the column with 1
molar oxalic acid so because we're
working on scaling up our production of
zirconium 89 and working on clinical
trials with this isotope we've worked on
automated separations and so this is why
I have biomedical engineering students
in my lab is because they work a lot on
these automated chemistry systems so
they basically take the chemistry we've
developed this is the dissolution vessel
so this is where we're dissolving that
coin target up in hydrochloric acid and
then all remotely we can move this onto
this column here where we can elute out
our it's room 89 in the water and our in
hydrochloric acid and then we can elute
our zirconium 89 in the oxalic acid and
this is all controlled by LabVIEW and it
has been programmed by one of my
undergraduate students so we use their
coding 89 to do imaging with antibodies
antibodies as you may know are these
proteins that can be engineered with
very high specificity to certain targets
on different cells we combine this with
the very high sensitivity of PET imaging
and so we can make molecular imaging
agents that are very specific and very
sensitive for certain receptors so
antibodies and antibody fragments are
very selectively targeting agents and
there's been a wide variety of antibody
based therapeutics that have been
developed in the last two decades every
time you see you know a news release
from a radio pharmaceutical company that
says something something mad that isn't
antibody based therapeutics and in fact
probably half
the therapeutics coming out of the
pipeline today are all antibody based so
the idea is we can use these antibody
imaging techniques to offer the
potential of stratifying patients that
may benefit from anybody therapy
monitoring the course of these therapies
and also paving the way for the next
generation of targeted therapies so
we've done a lot of work on with an
antibody that targets something called
the human epidermal growth factor to
will call this her - so her - is a
transmembrane receptor so it basically
spans the cell membrane has a piece
that's inside and a piece that's outside
it doesn't have any known natural
ligands and it's amplified in about 20%
of invasive breast cancer patients that
are her2 positive have increased tumor
aggressiveness they are shown to be
resistant to certain types of therapy
and typically have increased mortality
so there are several hurt - antibody
targeted therapeutics so the first one
is trust choose a map so this is shown
here trust - so map is an antibody that
binds what we call domain for this is
the domain that's close to the cell
membrane and it works by suppressing the
downstream signaling of the her2
receptor the other antibody that's
available is called / - zermatt it binds
the domain - so this is a little bit
farther away from the cell membrane and
it works by inhibiting the her2
dimerization with other receptors so
again inhibiting the function of the
her2 receptor there's also a newer
compound called TDM one that is based on
trust whose map but is linked to a toxin
called GBM one when this is internalized
it essentially releases the toxin and
the toxin interferes with cell growth
and proliferation so there's these three
targeted therapeutics and but they only
work if the patients are her2 positive
so we started with test use map trust
use map is an fda clinically approved
antibody i just shown here this is the
package insert and so the idea is is
that a trust use a web imaging agent may
be useful for determining ghost
strategies and for predicting who may
respond well the trust use a map therapy
how they do this now is they take a
biopsy they'll do staining for looking
for the her2 receptor but patients her
to status can change over the course of
therapy and even if a patient has
widespread metastasis you can see cells
that have her to positivity and her to
negativity and so you really want to
know whose crew to her2 positive in
order to determine who would be
well-suited for this type of targeted
therapy so what we wanted to do was
develop an imaging agent that was based
on trust use a map so we have this DFO
so this is our key later that's going to
hang on to our zirconium and then this
NCS functional group this NCS functional
group basically we can attach it to
these free licensing groups on the
antibody and then they can create our
antibody key later conjugate after we
have our antibody key later conjugate we
can radio label it with our zirconium 89
giving rise to our zirconium 89 key
later and that thus our targeted
radiopharmaceutical and a lot of this
was pioneered by a group in the
Netherlands so what we want to do first
was make sure that our zirconium 89
trastuzumab still targets her2 positive
cells so what you're looking at here is
what we call a PET CT image and the CT
is essentially just like a
three-dimensional x-ray so that
three-dimensional x-ray is windowed for
the bone here so you see that in gray
and the pet is the orange here so in
this way we can get an overlay of the
functional imaging or where the her2 is
and the the anatomy which is what the CT
is showing you so these are animals that
were implanted with her2 positive cells
and her2 negative cells so these are the
positive these are the negative we
inject the animals and then we image
them at 24 hours post injection 24 hours
post injection you see high up taking
the her2 positive cells and lo I've
taken the her2 negative however at 24
hours post injection you still see a lot
of background here so this is in the
blood pool but this is because the
antibody
has a very long circulation half-life
and you also see some signal coming from
the spleen if we take those same animals
because this is non-invasive imaging we
can image them in 96 hours after
injection here we see the her2 positive
here we see the her2 negative you can
see that a lot of that background as
faded out and we really have very nice
tumor delineation and high up taking the
her2 positive tumor and low uptake in
the her2 negative tumor we've also done
what we call a micro metastasis model so
here we've taken our her2 positive cells
and transfected them with an optical
imaging agent when we inject them in the
tail vein we can get very very small
tumor metastasis so here's one in the
jaw and one in the spine that are
optically active so we know where the
cells are and then we can image this
with our zirconium 89 trust use a map
and even in these very very small
lesions so these are about a millimeter
across we see high uptake of the
zirconium 89 signal again both in this
jaw lesion and in the spine lesion so
moving forward with this we were really
happy to partner with frota - dia
Washington University to move forward
with a clinical trial and so the idea is
is can we use the zirconium 89 trust use
map to identify lesions that were her2
positive and to identify lesions that
were her - negative this is one of our
early studies so I'm just showing here
the PET imaging you see somewhat liver
in the background and you still see some
blood pool this is actually one of our
patients that had already had a double
mastectomy so she doesn't have cancer in
the breast area however you can see this
lesion here this is in the femur and
this is a known her - positive patient
and so we are very excited about this
preliminary result so we move forward
this is going to work ok we move forward
we were imaging patients again two days
and five days after injection because we
want to see how well we can image as
time progresses so this is a patient at
two days after injection you can see
still quite a bit of blood pool so this
is the heart here
you can see some uptake in the liver and
then mrs. excretion through the bowel
but even a two days post injection you
can see significant uptake in the
shoulder lesion in this hip lesion and
in this femur lesion this again just
shows the PET CT just sort of show it
focusing in on the shoulder lesion here
this is the same patient five days after
injection so again showing the shoulder
lesion hip lesion and thigh lesion and
showing a little bit that the blood pool
clears out at this later time point this
is an interesting study because so this
is the same patient so you see the
shoulder hip and thigh lesion this
patient also had a CT scan to look at
her the extent of her cancer so the CT
scan was in April whereas our scan was
in May this was not identified on CT
however we did identify it with the the
PET scan and in August of this year this
patient again had a CT scan and now this
was identified so this in this one
anecdotal study we actually did see it
before it was evident on CT this is one
of our other images again just showing
that we are able to look at a primary
breast cancer in in the breast here so
here you see two lesions this patient
actually has two two lesions called
multicentric primary breast cancer and
this study is continuing on so we're
continuing on both at Washington
University and we're starting a new
cohort at University of Alabama at
Birmingham as well and so we're starting
this trial and will actually be imaging
patients and then looking at
correlations with response to targeted
her to therapy so we're really excited
to start that study here I wanted to
give another example about how we can
use this technique in radiotracers
outside of medicine and so we recently
became very interested in a compound
called P fats or our family of compounds
called PFS so Kieff as our per floral
alkylated compounds they are very
persistent
Queens they accumulate both in plants
and animals and they have toxicity a
possibility both in biological organics
there are very stable compounds so this
means they have very slow breakdown in
the environment and they hang around for
a long period of time these P fast
compounds are widely used in a lot of
different products and typically they're
used to make products more resistant to
stains grease and water such as nonstick
cookware stain resistance and carpets
and furniture waterproofing mattresses
and also in firefighting materials so
some of the PFS compounds such as P of
OS is no longer manufacturing and they
are phasing out some of these but there
are other derivatives that can still do
harm and these compounds again still
hang around the environment for a long
time so I'm just showing here these are
some of the different compounds in this
family of PFS so PETA's can be found in
water supplies from long-term
contamination partly from firefighting
foam they're also found in fast-food
materials
wrappers other materials and they're
known to bioaccumulate and there's also
been several reports of environmental
contamination from spills and so this is
a lake that was found to be heavily
polluted with PFS because it was
actually nearby a military base where
they use a lot of firefighting foam
this is Hoosick Falls this was in the
news lately and previously known as New
York State's best-tasting water found to
have high contamination of PFS because
they were near a fairly significant
industrial processing plant so our plan
was to look at radioactive versions of
PFS to look at routes of bile
accumulation and the kinetics so we
thought as usually we do that
radiotracers are very useful tools and
that we could radio label our PFS with
fluorine-18 so again instead of labeling
our sugar molecules we're labeling these
environmental contaminants and so we did
a study where we labeled these three
different compounds we call buta hexa
and octa PF ba PF h XA PFOA and injected
them in mice to look at the
clearance kinetics so Jennifer Berg
Kemper who is a chemist in my group
developed this chemistry so you have
your fluorine-18 separation from the
target material she dries it down
because this chemistry only goes
invariant hydrous hydrous conditions and
then did some radio labeling so we're
essentially able to switch out some of
these fluorines that are attached to
this molecule for our fluorine-18
radioactive atom then we have a tracer
that we can use for these compounds so
we looked at the kinetics in mice and we
actually found a lot of differences
between these families of compounds we
were able to see differences in the
blood differences in the lung liver and
also most interestingly difference in
brain uptake so even very small changes
in the structure of these compounds led
to fairly dramatic changes in the bio
distribution we also looked at blood
binding and we're able to see very
different behaviors of these compounds
in in order to look in order to our site
with the blood banking in these animals
and so it's really interesting we found
these new tools that we can use to sort
of monitor in these environmental
contaminations so we have this new tool
to study the biological distribution of
PFS and we're starting to look at
different families of these PFS
structures we also had some thoughts
that we could use some environmental
remediation studies so the idea is is
imagine if you have some water that's
contaminated with PFS and you want to
know how are you going to clean up the
water well we could take some water
samples and spike them with our
radioactive materials and put them
through different filters to different
treatment strategies and assess
quantitatively how well we were cleaning
up those water samples so we're working
on these molecular imaging agents so the
primary focus is in in medicine we're
also doing some of these studies in in
the environmental space but we continue
to expand our toolbox and so I've talked
a little bit about fluorine we talked
about zirconium but we're also
interested in manganese cobalt yttrium
and so we're continually working on new
radio isotopes for our new tracers so
one of my postdocs Lauren Radford is
been working on COBOL 55 production this
is by a PN reaction on nickel 58 so what
she's working on is essentially
electroplating our nickel 58 onto these
coins so we can irradiated argit's to
make our cobalt 55 then she's working on
separation strategies to separate our
cobalt 55 from our nickel 58 and this is
just showing the electroplating system
so we have our gold coin that sits on
the bottom here and then we have our
anode rod that's used to electroplate
our nickel 58 onto that gold coin we're
working on radio chemistry of this folic
acid targeting agent so this is a
collaboration with a group in
Switzerland and so we're starting the
chemistry and then we'll start some cell
work to look at the binding capabilities
in the imaging quality of our new cobalt
55 imaging agent we're also working on
manganese 52 this is an interesting pet
and analog for manganese MRI agents
manganese plays important biological
roles in both plants and animals and
we're also very interested in mechanism
of manganese toxicity which is known as
mechanism so in certain in certain types
of industries namely in welders or
manufacturing people that are exposed to
high concentrations of manganese can
actually accumulate manganese in the
brain and so here this is actually a
welder that had been exposed to high
concentrations of manganese and you can
actually see this bright spot so this
bright spot is actually natural
manganese that this patient was exposed
to that is picked up on the MRI so we're
looking at making manganese by a PN
reaction on chromium 52 this is a PET
imaging agent so again we're looking at
some imaging studies and we're looking
at the ability to image this
quantitatively and comparing the images
that we get to other isotopes so we have
fluorine 18
sixty-four HR maybe six or coning 89 and
then we have our manganese 52 agent and
so you can see that the manganese agent
is you can get very clear and crisp
images so we're very excited to use
these these manganese compounds in
further imaging studies we're looking at
this production by the chromium d2 PN
reaction so we figured out certain
methods to make chromium foils so we use
these chromium foils to do the target
development we've looked at yield
measurements so this is just showing the
yield of manganese 52 this is the
probability that that nuclear reaction
is going to happen and then we've done a
lot of separation studies looking at the
best way to separate our manganese 52
from that chromium target material we're
also looking at how to electroplate the
chromium target material so we can do
this in a more routine fashion Adriana
and Mexicano who is one of my postdocs
again has worked a lot on how to
electroplate enriched chromium onto
these copper coins and then we've done
some very preliminary studies again
looking at the bio distribution of
manganese the imaging quality and then
we'll start looking at different
manganese complexes and how they behave
and so we're really excited to move
forward in these new directions so I
thank everybody for their time and I
hope I managed to convince you that
radioisotopes they play a really
important role in medicine and in other
areas of science there's a wide variety
of half-lives there's good imaging
characteristics and new chemistry's that
can lead to a unique tool box for the
development of new nuclear medicine
imaging agents and also therapeutics and
of course development and use of these
agents requires a lot of collaboration
both between chemists physicists
biologists and physicians so and here's
our group who does a lot of the work
this is my email if people are
interested and I'm very happy to answer
any further questions great thank you
thank you so much can you unshare the
slides here
now we have few more minutes of 6 7
minutes so I have a few questions about
like how long does it take well to make
like start from the scratch like for
example manganese you started recently
so how long does it take to get the
whole thing ready to start some clinical
tests are like even in the labs so in
the lab so we usually start out with
preparation of the targets and it
depends on the compound that we're using
to as a target material and so Adriana
has been working a lot on the target
materials so maybe that took a couple
weeks then we do some very low level
radiation so we make very small amounts
of manganese we practice our separation
chemistry and then and then we start
working on the chemistry and again it
depends how complicated each step is
along the way we do the separation
chemistry then we try to conjugate it to
certain targeting agents and so you know
these these projects with these isotopes
can be years long definitely ok and like
like do you collaborate with other I
mean like you know cities where you can
I mean like this is what I see is a
useful research tool to do so many
things like so how like have you been
looking into collaboration with other
universities other people like a lot of
collaborations so that that work on the
P pass work that's a collaboration with
University of Notre Dame we we continue
to collaborate with Washington
University for the zirconium unite rest
use map so ya know we're a very
collaborative group and we also welcome
you know we have collaborations both on
people that are interested in making
isotopes and with people that just have
new questions that we can probe with our
tools so we will also we have I didn't
talk a lot about this but we also our
Center for shipping isotopes so let's
say somebody else is really interested
in using zirconium 89 for imaging we can
actually manufacture zirconium 89 ship
it to them so that we can support their
chemistry as well and like since it
remains in the body for 3-4 days
so have you looked at that toxicity of
the radioisotope or anything all they
raise levels no that's a very good
question so we get very very low amounts
of radioactivity that's a very nice
thing about PET imaging is it's very
very high sensitivity so you're really
giving tracer amounts very very low
amounts there's no biological effect
from me sir
the amount that you're getting is was
probably on par with having a CT scan so
if you've ever had a CT scan for you you
know being your head or had an injury or
something that's the kind of levels of
radiation that we're talking about okay
and with the patient's like you inject
them like it doesn't have any side
effects or anything like that that's
what I mean it's the same the amount of
radiation are very very low it's like
having an x-ray okay and how you thought
out this is kind of like patting
something business because this I see
there is a big potential for it to be a
big penis so there are businesses um
there are commercial businesses that do
make ftg or make that sugar analog um
and so usually once something's been FDA
approved then and we're using it a lot
of patients then the businesses will get
involved at the research stage I mean
we're a university so that's where we
say and that's where my heart is tumors
in the research side okay I think I
don't have any more questions right now
and I didn't take this opportunity to
thank you for your time and effort it's
really very nice to like I learned a lot
of things like I'm not my brain is
really tell okay we could have done this
defector we had these kind of resources
when yeah I mean like especially you are
talking about all these glutamate
receptors and all those things so there
is a lot of work going on and with your
tool I mean like that's a lot of
important things could be achieved yeah
a lot of work is been going on with
Alzheimer's disease and imaging other
deposition that sort of thing - oh okay
okay again thank you so much
we appreciate your time and good luck
with all the things you are doing thank
you nice to meet you